i actually really enjoy over the top the
movie with uh sylvester stallone where
he's a trucker
it's like a father-son movie
it's uh you know like a bunch of sports
have the definitive movie the boxing has
rocky maybe folk style collegiate
wrestling has uh vision quest
um what else is there billiards his
color of money yeah this is
uh the sort of movie for arm wrestling
so what did over the top get right what
did he get wrong about arm wrestling
that was actually based off of a real
story a lot of people don't know that
now the over the top movie
i mean to a certain degree
that's actually real life like that
tournament over the top was real yeah it
was literally named over the top yes yes
there was a trucker division and the guy
actually won a truck for real his name
is john berzing you know who that is
right so the actual over-the-top
tournament the trucker division was won
by john who is john bozenk he he is a
lot of people talk about him
as like a legend and uh one of if not
the greatest arm wrestlers of all time
john brzenk is
every
arm wrestler's
father to a certain degree
all of us um
the entire sport looks up to him
uh he
it's incredible what he's done i mean at
18 he won over the top
at 57
he just competed with me a couple months
ago
still at the world level 18 that's 40
years of being at the top of the sport
it's incredible uh he's hailed as the
greatest of all time in the sport arm
wrestling um yeah and he doesn't he's
beating some monsters oh yeah yeah and
he doesn't
i mean when you talk about like the uh
the evolution of the sport
he's responsible for so much of it like
when you talk about like a lot of times
when you go back like 20 years 30 years
a lot of us looked at arm wrestling
i think it's i mean
as something you could kind of do
and he's the first guy who's like if you
want to get better at arm wrestling you
got arm wrestle
and it seems so simple
but
you know he answered so many questions
that all of us had about techniques in
the sport
uh back you know pre
pre-video internet um
yeah he's everybody he's been
everybody's target for like 40 years so
in terms of strength there's a power in
terms of skill what did he teach the
sport of arm wrestling so if you look
how did the sport change from 80s 90s to
uh the arts
you were at the top of the world for
many years you know
many argue you're still at the very top
of the world but like you were very
dominant both left and right hand in uh
i don't know 2008 to
2013 something like that yeah
so how did that sport evolve to today so
it's hard for me to comment you know
prior to
you know when i came to the sport was
kind of mid-90s like i've been arm
wrestling my whole life but
uh i wasn't really involved in the sport
to a a major degree until probably you
know mid-90s
but i'll say that
before the mid-90s
it was really hard to get good at arm
wrestling very difficult
um everybody was doing it wrong really
like it was really rare to find people
who were technically good arm wrestlers
it was very underground you know when i
when i got into the sport it was a flyer
that came in the mail
you had to know somebody who knew
somebody who knew somebody and then you
go to a club and you can't do anything
with these people
and
and they'll and they knew how to arm
wrestle they did but real masters were
rare and
you know then internet internet helped
everybody communication
the transfer of knowledge became so much
faster
people became technically
you know invested
people started train
sharing sharing ideas
by i'd say
two thousand and
well probably around the turn of the
millennia
i'd say that professional leagues
started to slowly pick up
more organized
bigger productions started attract more
athletes
more people took it seriously
by 2010
i'd say there was another jump
um
more serious leagues a little bit more
money
by 2015
more major media like people were
investing a lot of money like uh
you know millionaires billionaires type
of people were organizing events setting
up leagues
and uh yeah i mean the past five years
it's just blown up uh the techniques i
mean if if i was to go back to when i
started
you know what what took me 10 or 15
years to learn i mean new guys are
showing up and they've got it down in
like a year
you